[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique aujourd'hui troisième chapitre
d'une série de quatre émissions
consacrées aux maires des grandes villes
de bourgogne dans la perspective bien
sûr des élections municipales de mars et
après lé maire du creusot de nevers et
avant celui de dijon nous recevons
aujourd'hui le maire d'auxerre bon genre
différent bonjour vous avez été élu en
2001 vous terminez donc votre troisième
mandat vous n'avez pas encore annoncer
vos intentions pour une éventuelle
candidature en mars prochain
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est un secret
de polichinelle je sais pas si c'est un
secret de polichinelle polichinelle par
dom et vous y verrez plus clair vendredi
rue vite puisque c'est le 18 octobre
vendredi prochain que j'annoncerai ma
candidature je peux peut-être vous donne
à dissimuler vous savez il ya d'anciens
retour de république on lisait sur et
vous candidat à votre succession et ce
président aurait pour des baisers libye
poussent des adversaires le redoute ça
peut-être vous donnez là et ça nous
donne un indice c'est une information
effectivement dans cette émission on va
dire qu'on se rapproche votre
candidature pour un quatrième mandat on
l'aura compris quand on dirige une ville
depuis 18 ans qu'est ce qui vous pousse
à continuer si c'est la décision que
vous prenez quelques jours là-bas
décision sur un fondée sur deux ou trois
éléments d'abord robert
c'est une personnalité et donc c'est
quelqu'un que plongé en permanence dans
la réalité dans la réalité vécue avec
ses concitoyens et donc il me semble que
les concitoyens mais citoyen concitoyens
les citoyens de serre considère il me
semble en tout cas que de larges parties
considèrent qu'il est encore du travail
à accomplir 2014 une gagner qu'avec 312
voix d'avancé
est ce que vous y avez vu un signe un
message ou ouvrir une pression dans ce
que j'ai vu en 2014
à l'époque j'étais berre avec
l'étiquette ps et à l'époque vous
rappelleront 2014 tout ce qui portait
une étiquette ps devait être tué et donc
je suis fils à bois des rares baer qui
dans notre pays avec l'étiquette ps a
survécu à l'époque et donc je pense que
c'est une situation particulière
véro pour l'approché de croire la région
nous étions de 2,2 bert à porto le stock
qui sont restés en place à ce pourquoi
là avant que vous nous disiez ce que
vous voulez faire et puis parliez de ce
que vous avez fait on a demandé aux
auxerrois ce qu'ils pensent de leur
ville j'aime j'aime pas des questions
posées par baasiste des outils et clan
2e d'une de nos équipes à auxerre on les
écoute et c'est vraiment nul
c'est un marché on y va il fait froid il
n'y a rien c'est vrai qu'un s'est passé
pas c'est pas accueillants voilà voilà
le mot il arrivait pas qu'il y en a chez
courir donc ils parlent de leur faire
mais quand on sait pas nick equideow qui
ont été refaits c'est bien on peut
marcher on peut j'aime bien l'action
qu'il a eue en matière d'urbanisme avec
la rénovation des quais voilà c'est ça
fait d'auxerre une ville je trouve
agréable dans laquelle on peut se
ressourcer et qui a pas forcément dans
d'autres villes il a su préserver le
caractère calme de la ville
je pense qu'il fait déjà ils essayent de
faire un maximum pour la ville
je pense qu'ils l'ont fait déjà pas mal
parce que on va dire que depuis quelques
temps elle en train enfin la vie je
parle elle en train d'essayer de
renaître de ses cendres
je sais qu'ils sont en train de faire
des travaux sur les quais les quais qui
est quand même un endroit phare à
auxerre que beaucoup de jeunes
apprécient y compris aussi petit et
grange pas donc je pense que non ça va
il fait du mieux qu'il peut le côté très
négatif c'est l'e commerce en
centre-ville qui meurent quoi moi
j'arrive pas à comprendre quelle est la
politique de la ville avec la zone
commerciale des clairions de
stationnement par exemple est gratuit et
puis en centre ville ici où le
stationnement est payant sauf une
demi-heure donc j'ai du mal à comprendre
cette politique
alors c'est un résumé bien sûr ça ne
vaut pas ce sondage les quais les gens
adorent
on va pas rentrer dans le détail on va y
rentrer par la suite sur le maire il
entend ces choses là quand il quand il
se promène en ville on lui on lui dit ce
qui va ce qui ne va pas ab ce que je
viens d'entendre je l'entends tous les
jours et si vous le permettez je réponde
au tableau au monsieur qui dit le marché
il est ce qu'il est donc il est pas beau
il dit qu'il va le refaire le berre oui
il va être refait et je suis je vais
débuter les travaux dès l'an prochain
pour des raisons très simples volonté de
le refaire et puis je tenais une
subvention de 500 mille euros de la
région que j'aurais utilisé pour le
marché avant la fin 2020 donc si je te
rassure elle fera sentir des spectateurs
veulent voir dépenser l'argent on va en
parler bien sûr en vendant un changement
de la ville c'est ce qui vient
maintenant dans cet entretien on aurait
pu vous poser des questions on va vous
proposer des photos parce que ces photos
ont toutes quelque chose à voir avec
votre mandat et avec la campagne à venir
on va parler de la ville d'abord avec la
première photo vous le voyez fermeture
définitive une vitrine fermée
c'est un peu le cauchemar des maires des
villes moyennes en france le taux de
vacance commercial étaient assez
important à auxerre ils l'aident il est
encore quels sont les outils à la
disposition du on a entendu quelqu'un
tout à l'heure qui la disaient les
boutiques sont aussi des questions
quotidiennes c'est quoi les outils à la
disposition du maire il ya des outils
qui sont à porto d'abord le gouvernement
a lancé l'état a lancé à ce qu'on
appelle action coeur de ville donc hyper
v aubert de mobiliser des moyens à la
foire jeu pour cet exemple là c'était
d'immeubles qui est à vendre par exemple
je peux très bien si je pense qu'un
commerce peut s'y installer exercer le
droit de préemption dire acquérir ce
local
donc ce qui permettrait à ce moment là
dessus de pouvoir y installer à
commerçants et d'avoir à loyer qui
serait pas loyers qui serait celui du
marché à des problèmes des villes
moyennes
vous savez c'est que s'ouvrent les
loyers pour les locaux commerciaux ne
sont pas à la hauteur du marché souvent
ce sont des prix parisiens prix sont
trop élevés ils sont trop élevés et donc
mais nous le bol aux actions très fortes
notamment avec les agents immobiliers
spécialiste des locaux et j'ai appris
tout à l'heure juste avant de vous
rejoindre d'ailleurs que deux gros
locaux commerciaux du coeur de ville
plusieurs centaines de mètres carrés à
l'êta traquée c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle cela dit le travail est encore
devant nous et il faut empêcher bloquer
ou freiner le développement des zones
périphériques pour que les centres
survivre ça c'est bloqué ce que vous
rochelle ya si vous voulez y est aussi
dans cette affaire un comportement des
citoyens et d'où nous en sommes en
quelque sorte
au coeur de cette affaire nos
concitoyens ils veulent du commerce aux
pervers et ce qu'on appelait les
chrosômes commercial depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant j'ai dit dont on
arrêtait zone commerciale en des temps
ils veulent du commerce de coeur de
ville et en même temps nos concitoyens
ils recourent de plus en plus au
commerce par le let et qui fait des
dégâts considérables et sans doute
davantage de bas que de faux encore une
fois les galeries marchandes et les
autres commerciales de périphérie trois
fois en même temps s'assurer qu'ils sont
présents un mot comme sur le marché de
l'arquebusé dont parlait ces auxerrois
oui alors vous nous dites que vous allez
leur ferme on va se souvenir qu'il
devait déjà être refaits et que ce
projet avait été annulé c'était une
forme d'échec de vos mandats précédents
ce marché d'art que c'était une forme
d'échec je n'étais pas d'ailleurs la
création ou la rénovation plus
exactement du marché c'était la création
d'une place à vocation commerciale que
j'avais souhaité confier à des
partenaires privés
à ce moment là il a fallu que je dise
non parce que je n'étais pas suivi par
la population
aujourd'hui c'est une opération publique
de rénovation biseau valeur du marché 2
son parking et de l'ensemble de la place
qui l'entourent avec le lien très direct
faire de une recul en quelque sorte
entre le marché et le coeur de ville
parce que lorsque l'une sommesous marché
d'auxerre nous sommes à 50 mètres du
coeur de la ville allait autre sujet une
voiture c'est la photo qu'on les photos
qu'on va voir la circulation automobile
il est dit au sujet au sujet précédent
aussi est ce qu'il faut c'est pas une
photo de sernancelhe bonnes photos de
scènes quoique d'après ben non pas sur
autant de fil que ça mais quand même sur
des bouchons on nous en a parlé avant
l'émission
est-ce que d'abord il faut faire le
choix de la piétonnisation très forte
par exemple c'est le cas de ce qui se
passe à dijon avec une très grande zone
piétonne ou est-ce que la venue de
moyenne il faut concevoir ça autrement
quelle est votre vision est ce que vous
avez des projets pour un mandat futur là
dessus oui bien sûr il ya des projets
vous avez raison dans les villes bayed
dire il faut quelque chose qui ne soit
pas punitif au sort benneteau qu'il y a
eu deux bords de la part de locaux
situés la meilleur partage des espaces
publics dans le coeur de ville et
les travellings projet pardon sont
engagés puisque la grande place des
cordeliers dos et un parking on va dire
t'as pas partie du coeur de ville de
barr si je suis candidat et ses sujets
toujours aux affaires fera l'objet d'une
opération de réhabilitation sera plus un
parti ce sera plus un parking mais à
contrario à quelques centaines de mètres
de cette place des cordeliers temps sur
un corps grand parking aujourd'hui je
construire un parking comportera
plusieurs niveaux et donc qui permettra
ce mot-là de détester complètement la
place des cordeliers
tu sais pas la bonne photo mais ça s'en
rapproche
on a des gens qui nous ont contactés
sachant que vous veniez c'est les
riverains de toute une zone qu'on crée
une association saluer l'artiste est le
même les riverains du triangle infernal
qui demande une rocade sud à auxerre
lille aux états ils ont raison ils
jouent en réseau
si je peux prendre un petit peu de temps
sur sur cette affaire parce que je
connais bien j'ai envie de dire nos
habits darty parce que la réalisation de
ce concours le bossu d'auxerre est une
préoccupation des riverains disait du
d'auxerre et de l'auxerrois et bêtes des
élus au redoux s'est réduit pour les
élus qui arrivent pas prendre les élus
vont finir par y arriver
c'est un sujet compliqué d'où 3 et des
bons seulement eux
le projet de contrôle ben non seulement
des pas enterré bill collègues nouvelle
vigueur pour une raison très simple pour
le financement état régions villes
départements agglomérations
il manquait à des financeurs qui était
la région aujourd'hui la présidente de
région a décidé d'inscrire le projet
autour le bossu d'auxerre dans ce qu'on
appelle le schéma régional des
infrastructures ce qui signifie que de
bas la région qui jusqu'à présent
étaient absentes dans la clé de
financement & gas la région sera
présenté et donc j'ai plutôt une bonne
nouvelle et nous allons commencer à
discuter bientôt puisque tout ceci va
trouver sa place dans le contrat de plan
qui lie l'état et la région entend donc
bien fait de nous écrire avant votre
venue
on change de photos c'est un symbole
c'est le symbole de l'hôpital
c'est un sujet dans toute la france avec
la grève aux urgences
saleh particulièrement à auxerre avec
des informations alarmantes sur un
hôpital en faillite on parle de 26
millions de dettes
d'abord est-ce que vous le confirmer sur
la situation de quasi-faillite de
l'hôpital fait 6 millions 26 millions de
déficit donc il fallait réagir jusqu'à
présent l'agencé régionale de santé qui
en fait le véritable gouvernement hors
de l'hôpital a les deux de pures
d'économies en plus d'écologie et donc
qui au fil des ans ça ne fonctionnait
pas puisque trois quatre heures nous
sommes arrivés à vintimille et quel
regard du sort c'est là dessus vous le
sait qu'il est particulièrement mal
gérer l'hôpital d'auxerre qu'il est mal
dimensionné c'est qu'ils subliment
politique nationale de deux ou trois
réseaux s'ils voulaient d'abord vous
avez à juste titre pc ça dans un
contexte national puisque en 2018 ce
sera 700 millions d'euros de déficit sur
l'ensemble des hôpitaux d'autres pays
d'auch le grand phare qu'est
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
sur l'hôpital d'auxerre tant d'autres
aux hôpitaux
qu'est ce qui explique ce déficit
première barre à territoire dans lequel
les hôpitaux qui sont présents dans le
territoire de l'yonne à petit territoire
au nombre d'habitants eh bien il n'y a
pas de complémentarité il ya de la
concurrence btb chance un seul exemple
ça illustre bien je crois les choses on
parle de plateaux techniques des salles
d'opération sur auxerre on s'le
l'opération occupé à dos 2 65% à des
taux les plus faibles de la bourgogne
nous avons les bêtes sur sens nous avons
les bêtes dans des cliniques privées
donc on voit bien qui a nécessité de
réformer en quelque sorte l'offre de
soins nous sommes à la laddh havre j'ai
travaillé avec le directeur régional de
la rs d'ici la fin de l'année aide
financière sur love le président al aide
financière sur l'enveloppé nationale et
nous avons décidé ensemble y compris le
représentant du personnel y compris la
direction de l'hôpital de travailler sur
une modification de l'offre de soin dont
seulement à l'échelle de l'hôpital
d'auxerre à l'échelle de l'ensemble du
département pour éviter ces concurrence
très belle cède pour les uns et pour les
autres
alors on a parlé infrastructures
aménagement avant de parler avant de
passer à la politique est ce qu'il ya
est-ce que vous avez un grand projet est
ce que vous avez un pyramide quelque
chose d'important que vous aimeriez
faire dans un hypothétique quatrième
mandat à dans un hypothétique quatrième
bordage une vision de la ville qui me
conduit
un maître priorité j'allais dire ce que
j'appelle une mutation de la ville nous
évoquions quelques aménagements y
quelques espaces publics
après le travail que j'ai bien accompli
j'ai envie de modifier complètement
l'image de la ville ou plus exactement
parfaire l'image de la ville qui a déjà
connu sous les différents bordas que
j'exerçais qu'a déjà connu une petite
mutation
je vous souhaite aller beaucoup plus bas
je souhaite qu auxerre soit tout à fait
un modèle survie dans un modèle de ville
à vivre et je suis convaincu que 2 bat
d'ailleurs c'est la vraie vie où la vie
paisible et la vie à g ne sera pas dans
les métropoles
elle sera dans les villes wyeth dans la
mesure aussi vu des moyennes sont
capables d'être attractive
ce sont des villes qui ont l'esprit
d'initiative
ce sont des victimes beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise notamment tpe sont
également à la main d'oeuvre et je peux
vous assurer que je sens les ferments de
latérite mardi dabic et d'une ville qui
est capable de battre monnaie la
campagne a commencé on a bien compris on
va faire un petit peu politique
différent parce qu une élection mais
municipal c'est ça aussi
vous avez soutenu manuel macron la
présidentielle aux législatives et aux
européennes est ce que vous êtes un
marcheur je suis à l'aube libre non ce
n'est pas de la langue de bois pas
pourquoi si je dois repartir
je repars sans éthique et ce que j'ai
dit il y a quelques semaines si je
repars sans étiquette et qui veut suivre
suivra qui mel b bat parce que je
considère aujourd'hui je vous disais
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans les
propos liminaires
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens que veulent
t'ils ils veulent à berre
rappelez vous il ya quelques jours
record sondage national quel est le
public préféré des français
c'est le berre parce que le berre est
capable de dépasser les clivages aubert
est capable de transcender la variété
numéro mail du séqué au ps depuis 1981
1983 1981 ou 80 voilà j'y vois là oui à
quel moment vous vous êtes dit ça marche
plus je m'en vais écouter sous le cac et
d'haulotte j'ai eu le sentiment d'amour
dit les choses comme je les pense parce
que je ne parle pas de look de voix
c'est eu le sentiment que le président
avait du mal à vouloir marier les tout
et son contraire
et donc je me suis dit qu'il suit avec
effectivement ça va de soi et puis je me
suis dit aussi que ce parti socialiste
avait pas du tout changé allez dire ça à
sa vision de ce qu'est la société des
évolutions de coller à ses évolutions et
je me suis dit que les plus grand chose
à y faire et on le voit aujourd'hui nous
avons d'un côté gauche henry lé parce
que ce que je dis pour le parti
socialiste
ça vaut aussi pour les autres partis de
gauche et quand je regarde à droite
c'est également un jour duruy donc je
considérerais d'une fonction de bercé
qui doit primer c'est l'intérêt général
au delà les opinions des uns et des
autres mais quand même parce que vous
savez que on est bien l'ironie aussi
vous le conseil fédéral de l'yonne a
voté le soutien à votre candidature
alors que vous n'êtes plus membre du ps
et que vous avez eu le soutien de la
république en marche c'est donc
totalement contraire à toutes les
consignes d'olivier fort le patron du ps
est ce que ça veut dire que vous tirez
toujours les ficelles du ps dans l'yonne
est ce que ça veut dire vous avez des
partisans au ps où est ce que ça veut
dire qu'au ps de l'yonne et des
sympathisants la république en marche
donc ça veut dire tout simplement parce
que je dois au cab obama devrait dans
les coulisses d'abord ce dépanneur de
nature plus chaud coin comme horrible à
la porte il avait tenté de tirer les
ficelles
c'est tout simplement et ça j'en suis
convaincu que j'apparais aussi bien la
république en marche qu'au parti ce
siège à paris sans doute comme adobe
d'unité et de rassemblement de ce qui me
satisfait après l'élection si vous êtes
candidat
si vous êtes élu est-ce que la
république en marche pour raconter
auxerre dans les villes gagnées ou est
ce que le ps vous raconter auxerre caen
les villes
conservez vous autorise recchi à se
revendiquer de vous je demanderai au
préfet de l'yonne de l'inscrire dans la
catégorie divers vous vous ne souhaitez
pas que la république en marche face
d'auxerre une des villes qui sont passés
de marque chez chip iphone au stade de
la république au parc je suis pas mort
du parti socialiste et pourtant
aujourd'hui le soutien et des entités un
autre logo politique
europe ecologie les verts à auxerre
comme à peu près partout en fait on
doctrine commencent à apparaître il
décide de quitter les majorités dans les
qualifiés pour une candidature
indépendante est ce que ça veut dire que
vous n'avez pas fait assez pour
l'environnement ou qu'il pense que vous
ne ferez pas assez par la suite on
écoute et j'analyse les choses de la
manière suivante europe ecologie les
verts et des cures européenne
un score qui en moyenne nationale comme
à auxerre d'ailleurs aidé un peu plus de
13%
je dis souvent c'est un bon score mes
yeux doux si leurs notes 87% à côté et
donc europe ecologie les verts riches en
quelques chants sur une doctrine que
j'appelle la doctrine jadot c'est de
dire on va casser la baraque vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et j'ai le
sentiment à auxerre comme ailleurs qui
veulent montrer débusque pour essayer de
mieux négocier au second tour ça s'est
bien passé ça s'est bien passé je sais
ça s'est très bien passé je peux vous
assurer enfin quand on travaille sur un
projet municipal
il est nourri par toutes celles et tous
ceux qui participent à ce projet cette
équipe municipale
nous avons travaillé beaucoup travaillé
et j'ai la faiblesse de dire bien
travailler et tout ceci sous l'autorité
et donc les verts j'allais dire europe
ecologie les verts s'ils ont pu
travailler à mes côtés et souci parce
que je leur ai confié des dossiers du
dren importance vous êtes prêt à
discuter encore avec eux par la suite
souvent d'entre deux tours aux
municipales en fait parfois beaucoup
trop tard pour faire votre vie votre
ville douce à vivre votre projet d'une
ville on ne peut plus de sa vivre il
faudrait peut-être des écologistes non
mais je peux la faire y compris sur les
écologistes le message message est passé
un mot sur le résultat des européennes
sur la ville d'auxerre la république en
marche 23%
le rassemblement national 22% tout c'est
votre adversaire principal pour ces
élections municipales
non je ne crois pas d'abord parce qu'on
ne peut pas trop se poser l'élection
européenne sur une élection municipale
je crois que tous les analystes
confirment ce que j'ai à te dire très
difficile aujourd'hui de lire je suis
convaincu que le front national ferait
un score qui lui permettra sans doute
d'être présent au second tour je crois
que c'est qu'à petit doigt qui en tout
cas la probabilité aux dernières
municipales en 2014 il manquait trop de
voix au front national pour être présent
au second tour
donc je ne sais pas du tout qui sera
beau où l'adversaire principal au second
tour s'il ya un second tour
et si vous êtes candidat
je suis candidat avec un peu d'ironie en
2014 votre challenge r c'était guillaume
larrivé députés on se rappelle que la
bataille avait été rude
312 voix d'avancé seulement à la fin
vous n'arrivez n'y retourne pas il lança
sa place le maire d'une autre commune de
l'yonne alors ce maire il a aussi croisé
la république en marche à un moment
donné si j'ai bien compris
écoutez il faut un quinze jours hobby
explique le parcours politique de ce
bear ducobu delà de l'agglomération
j'avais entendu dire cela aujourd'hui il
est adoubé par les républicains très sûr
genre je ne regarde pas ça de près parce
que je trouve que c'est pas très beau
pour les serrois c'est pas très beau
pour auxerre ne pas avoir trouvé dans la
ville d'auxerre un candidat ou une
candidate susceptibles de représenter la
droite républicaine
je trouve qu'il y ait un certain mépris
à l'égard des auxerrois
une autre photo et ce sera notre notre
dernière photo qui nous renvoie un an en
arrière c'est la photo du mouvement des
gilets jaunes
le mouvement était fort dans l'yonne on
se rappelle des ronds-points de sens qui
avait été violé mais il ya eu aussi des
ronds points auxerre qui ont été très
occupés assez longtemps est ce que vous
l'avez compris ce mouvement est ce que
vous l'avez craint comment ça c'est
comment vous l'avez vécu je l'ait
compris je n'ai pas créé sur la ville
parce que dès le mouvement dès le départ
du mouvement des vigiles jaune tout de
suite les représentants des bouilles
gilet jaune
ceux d'auxerre et de l'auxerrois sow
venu me voir nous avons discuté j'ai
perçu j'ai perçu ce qui pouvait les
motiver et puis surtout j'avais passé un
deal avec eux avait demandé s'il pouvait
s'installer j'aurais dit écoutez c'est
pas compliqué il est besoin de salles de
tabre pour chirurgie d'accord ok il
condition c'est que sur auxerre ça reste
calme et c'est resté calme et ça m'a
permis d'être en réalité à les coudes
pendant tout ce mouvement qui
s'essouffle et dans ces manifestations
visibles en tout cas ça aurait permis
d'être père mais aussi l'écouté de
percevoir les attitudes côté relayé
d'ailleurs par nombre de français
qu'elle analyse vous en faites une
révolte contre la pauvreté avec un forte
pauvreté dans ce pays une réaction aussi
à des mesures environnementales parce qu
on se souvient que c'est l'augmentation
des prix de l'essence qui l'a provoquée
et télécoms
une contre les villes d'autres disent un
mouvement contre la république carrément
vous l'interprétez comment vous j'ai
envie de vous dire nous interprète un
peu comme et au révélateur sorte de
crise du modèle français crise sur le
pour des fonctions régaliennes regarder
les pompiers les hôpitaux la police je
pourrais multiplier les inquiétudes
aussi sur ce que sera demain la retraite
des français par exemple et donc c'est
un mouvement de fond et c'est pour ça
que je veux et je pense que c'est un
assez représentative d'une forme de
crise du modèle français et donc tous
attendent au de l'état du gouvernement
en particulier que l'ensemble de ces
sujets qui ne sont pas réglés
aujourd'hui il faut bien le dire est
qu'ils sont sous terrain parce que même
sous vaudoise au bois l'égide des jo
dans la rue il n'empêche que les
inquiétudes sont là et je crois que
notre société aussi doit prendre garde à
saint louis je pense qu'il ya une crise
du modèle français et la partie aux
pouvoirs publics de pouvoir y répondre
dans les meilleures conditions
alors vous acceptez le soutien d'un
public en marche mais vous critiquez
aussi le gouvernement sur ce qui n'a pas
fait vous savez je comme je suis pas
marcheurs je suis capable de souligner
ce que le gouvernement fait de bien et
comme je suis aussi adobe libre je suis
capable aussi des trades et guillon
parce que ce qui est en cause
aujourd'hui essais indépendants
d'ailleurs deux du gouvernement quel
qu'il se passe où l'on ne savait comment
celle ci s'était pas bac rond ce serait
quelqu'un d'autre il ya une crise du
modèle français il appartient aux
gouvernants au gouvernement et aux prêts
pluie de prendre la bonne mesure et du
pouvoir apporter les réponses mais j'ai
bien conscience aussi que les choses ont
pas se régler rapidement il faut du
temps parce que nous travaillons sur le
taux longs il ya auxerre il ya aussi une
périphérie autour une agglomération et
on sent l'inquiétude des des zones
périurbaines et de la campagne du monde
rural quand on est maire de la ville
centre
oui je vous le confirme il ya au serre
la vis autres il y a deux ou trois
villes qui colle directement auxerre et
puis aussi une partie rurale et je
mesure combien la ville sorte d'abord
peut faire peur aux communes rurales at
aurorise au pub pour debreu de vue c'est
à tort mais s'est assis et on va bien
qu'entre la sociologie si vous voulez y
compris la sociologie électorale de la
ville centre et de sa périphérie
eh bien il ya quand même une différence
et joue pas toujours facile et pâtures
fesses en début d'émission nous avons
fait écouter des avis des auxerrois à
bastia ou techno de l'eau
aussi demandé vous allez voir cette même
personne en fait il avait quelque chose
à vous dire on va les écouter ce qu'il
ya une action qui est possible en
matière de densification du centre du
centre-ville de serre qu'ils refassent
le marché couvert
comme il faut qui met beaucoup de choses
de danton piste aviez c'est si triste
marché couvert si triste faut que tu
m'appelles guy bas pour avoir des
nouvelles
non non mais je dirais continue dans sa
lancée
je pense que ce que tu es en train
d'accomplir ses biens si j'avais quelque
chose à lui dire c'est que j'aimerais
bien déjà qui clarifie sa position parce
que je trouve assez dommageable de se
faire élire socialiste et puis après
passé sous une autre étiquette je trouve
que c'est pas très respectueux des
électeurs qui ont voté pour lui à une
époque
alors voilà bon ça recoupe un certain
nombre de choses dont on parlait là vous
n'oublierez pas d'appeler le monsieur
qui vous demandent de l'appeler
absolument il ya un thème dont on n'a
pas du tout parlé dans les gens nous ont
pas parlé mais qui est assez présent
dans l'actualité ça prenne du collège
bienvenue martin à auxerre où j'avais
raison
alors il y avait des voix là ils
devaient être fermés pour des décisions
financières conseil départemental
maintenant c'est des problèmes
d'organisation et des opprimés
logistique
le maire il voudrait que son collège
reste ouvert écoutez le colère je suis
très clair le président du conseil des
parts au plus tôt l'assemblée
départementale a demandé aux préfets de
cire d'arrêté de fermeture du moulage de
vie martin ce collage risque de devenir
une friche dans un quartier qui fait
l'objet qui va cotiser de faire l'objet
d'opérations de renouvellement urbain
opposition aujourd'hui julie dit au
préfet je les dis au président du
conseil départemental
je veux récupérer ce collège dans le
giron de la ville pour faire un grand en
sorte de service à la population dans un
quartier qui fait l'objet d'opérations
de renouvellement urbain donc les élèves
eux partiront ailleurs mais vous
souhaitez conserver et ils le sont déjà
parties concernées le lieu en fait le
lieu je veux conserver le lieu on
approche à la fin de cette émission qui
fait rays
on vous a proposé comme à tous les
maires qui succède cette place pendant
sur notre plateau de faire un selphy
dans votre vie alors le voilà on va voir
la photo normalement qui va qui doit
apparaître s'est rapidement si on a de
la voix
bon alors on vous voit pas tendre le
bras
on va dire que c'est un semi selphy bon
pourquoi vous à cet endroit là bon pour
deux ou trois raisons parce que je
trouve que c'est un beau signe à leurs
voiliers à la jeunesse auxerroise et
départementale puisque nous sommes
devant une salle de diffusion des
musiques actuelles que vous appelons le
si l'accès c'est aussi très emblématique
de la politique culturelle que nous
conduisons dans la ville d'auxerre et
puis souci a beau message en date hier
au d'écologie développement durable
puisque nous avons dans ce dans cette
belle salle de diffusion début des
actuels ce qu'on appelle de la
géothermie qui alimente en énergie
ce bâtiment aux salles de diffusion des
musiques actuelles le si l'accès aux
messages que vous envoyez à europe
ecologie jean lassalle à la population
il nous reste une minute une minute
trente démission mais c'est suffisant
pour vous demander si vous avez un
regret dans le mandat qui se termine est
un rêve pour le mandat qui peut venir à
vous battre les deux connaître
faut-il avoir des regrets oui sans doute
que j'aurais pu aller plus vite sur
certains projets sur certains dossiers
bis ça c'est la vie d'albert si vous
voulez donc ça ne pose pas de difficulté
en termes de de regret pour demain j'ai
vraiment envie j'ai vraiment envie que
auxerre sera vain quand je dis que je
souhaite qu auxerre soit une ville à
vivre un modèle de ville à vivre je dis
pas ça par un excès de langage je crois
beaucoup à cela parce que je suis très
amoureux de ben ali
j'y suis né j'y suis encore ai-je envie
que tout le monde s'y sentent aussi bien
que moi le rennais symbole de cette
ville d'où ça vibre pour y avoir quelque
chose par un lieu nouveau quelque chose
s'est pas encore évoqué dans je vous
quitte tout à l'heure la place des
cordeliers le marché et puis j'ai
l'intention aussi de reprendre de larges
parties du corps dit ville précisément
pour qui ad'ailleurs partage entre les
utilisateurs ou les usagers de la ville
les bétons les voitures les vélos bref
tout ce qui fait dans une ville chacun
doit pouvoir sur goûterez ehab être
surtout la présence de l'homme merci
beaucoup différait ce pourrait être la
conclusion de cette émission
merci d'être venu nous voir dimanche
prochain à votre place ce sera le maire
de dijon françois rebsamen qui viendra
répondre à nos questions dans l'immédiat
rester avec nous pour la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
bon dimanche au revoir et merci au
revoir et merci
[Musique]